- Do you know what the Egyptians
do with lying,
worthless terrorists, Michael?
MICHAEL: I don't understand.
I gave you what you wanted.
Headquarters took
me off your case file,
and they're closing
your account.
They don't think that you know
anything about the prince.
Unless you can give me something
that proves that you were
close with him, something
that leads us to him,
you're on that plane.
Emir Al-Muttaqi introduced me.
MAN: How's it looking, Doc?
DOCTOR: Rehab should take
three months, maybe longer.
After rehab, you
should regain full use
of your wrist and your hand.
It's not that bad, really.
You know, oxy will
help speed things up.
Maybe a little Demerol, Vicodin.
Fentanyl.
Fentanyl's good.
Advil.
As I said, it's not that bad.
I need to show you something.
Bomb's gonna go off right here.
All these people, I
just see them dead.
If I wasn't thinking
about my job all the time,
how many more people like
this would be dead right now?
GINA: Tell me about that day,
the day you met Shishoni.
SHISHONI: Do you
know why you're here?
Muttaqi keeps talking about you.
As American, you'd be a
great asset to the cause.
Since when has an American not
betrayed those who trusted him?
I should kill you
where you stand.
GINA: Why didn't
the prince kill you?
MICHAEL: I gave him
something he needed.
We need a renewed vision.
We need to step into the
future, undermine their heroes,
and build up our own.
Where did you
find this genius?
I killed a boy in Fallujah
the day that Sarah died.
I think that Sarah's
death was God's punishment
for me killing that boy.
I-- I just can't get
it out of my head.
You know what I can't
get out of my head?
Her tiny dead body in my arms.
You think her death
is because of you?
Everything is about you,
always is, always will be.
Jade, for my cousin here.
He is a big hero.
[inaudible] texted me.
All right?
She's worried about you.
We got to get you home.
I had a [muted] day in the ER.
Kid died.
I just-- I want a minute, OK?
Have one drink with me, huh?
One drink, then we go.
[inaudible].
Come on, you're drunk.
Get off of me.
[non-english speech] You OK?
[both laughing]
I've seen too many
people die, man.
Something we have in common.
Yeah.
Come on.
Except I'm the one
trying to save their lives.
The anger that you feel,
that was put in your heart
to give you the
strength that you need
for the war that is to come.
And that victory will come
with the help of a single word.
And that word is vision.
GINA: So that's it?
That's all you got for me?
Some bull [muted] sermon
you gave him the idea for?
This is it.
This is the last conversation
you'll ever have.
What do you want me to say?
- I want the truth.
- You're OK.
You're fine.
I got you.
Hey, you're OK.
You're all right.
Go away.
Please go away.
What's going on in here?
- He fell.
- Go away.
Go away.
[moaning]
I've missed you.
How have you been?
Never better.
I can't tell if that's a
total lie or the truest thing
you've ever said to me.
MAN: Suddenly, the M1A1 has
had enough, fires back at him.
Boom!
Right?
The blast throws the due in the
air, incinerates his clothes,
splits him in two, right?
Now, when he lands, the bottom
half lands ass up, all right?
But the top half, his face--
guess you had to be there.
That's your plane.
Last chance, Michael.
Think hard.
I can prove it.
There's another grave on
the edge of the field.
You'll find a body
in it, a young boy.
I needed to see how far you're
willing to go for the cause,
for me.
But remember what happens
to those who betray me.
[gunfire]
Jesus.
WOMAN: Andrew Hall was
kidnapped eight hours ago.
The president's Andrew Hall?
Yes, and two of his aides.
It's part of the [inaudible]
movement led by--
Yeah, the prince.
Stay on him.
He's got to know more
about the prince's
network, anything
that will help us
find out where he's taken Hall.
GINA: Good news is you're
not going to Egypt.
What's the bad news?
We're still working together.
You were never going to
fly me to Egypt, were you?
Were you?
I need a gun to protect the
kids when you're not around.
Guns are my other life.
We're safe, Juanita.
I promise.
WOMAN: Really?
[music playing]
[gunshot]